we had a painful group date panas actual
illness and Luke's personal trauma
conversation never happened
this is our Bachelorette episode a three
recap so grab your glass it's time for
roses and rose they hi you guys i'm
lauren zima
and we are in pain yes what an episode
of The Bachelorette Hannah Browns third
app and oh my god I loved it I loved it
because of some of the painful parts of
it and this is making me question myself
wondering if I would say this or
masochist or actually what either those
words mean because I'll be honest I use
them interchangeably I don't think they
mean the same thing but you know what
I'm saying it's like deal of pain oh if
we don't know the pain we don't know the
pleasure you know what I'm saying I'm
making it weird let's move on what an
episode what did you guys think is this
season getting better and better for you
each week yes for me raise the pan
tolerance I can no I'm sorry I'm getting
weird I'm just being weird now just
being weird I'm just thinking about I
have 50 shades of gray on the mine
because I heard the emilia clark was
almost cast in a movie came out throws
reference and i would have liked it I
would have probably honest mr. grey will
see you now what do you think we are
going to kick things up with the group
date where the guys borderline got
kicked in the stomach by that labor
simulator machine what what what how
have we not done this group date before
I mean drink for every time they
shrieked in pain on this date
oh gosh
why aren't you already doing that
nothing so it's a group date where the
guys are gonna learn about what it's
like on some small level I think this is
a miniscule amount of knowledge that
they're getting today but we'll take it
what it's like for women to be pregnant
and go through labor we had guests group
daters they're not judges I don't know
what to call them they're making cameos
by the way I'm on cameo shameless blah
but seriously get the cameos if you want
to do them I'll sing you a song I like
doing them they're fine
so Jason Biggs American Pie star and
Jenny Moll and his wife are there they
were great super fun they're big
bachelor fans first they're tested on
their knowledge of pregnancy but Tyler's
description wasn't wrong but it was wild
I don't really know too much about
pregnancy but that your belly gets
bigger and bigger and the woman gets
hungry and hungry so and then there was
Jed which organ does a woman grow during
pregnancy Jed
nice work oh you guys drink every time
you loved Jed this episode I am getting
more and more obsessed with him
each time he talks because he always
says something smart are mature or
talented how much do you love Jed is
here front-runner right now for Hannah
for yourself whatever it let me know to
look him at her for Hannah are you
thinking about maybe as a bachelor tough
call
I'm saying for Hannah I think is the
modern siren guy that she needs anyway
points for jet drinks for Jed he knows
that as the placenta is what gets bigger
I'll be honest I'm not even sure I knew
that like in my mind I was thinking
wrong
what is the one really I need to
understand myself better but good job
Jed and I love this labor simulator
thing I'm fascinated by it and the guys
reactions when they were getting zapped
unbelievable Tyler's saying there was
like is like arm pose and I was so glad
everybody called him out on it I've
heard online that Tyler works as a model
which I see I mean II was really
modeling great and
he's like trying not to show that they
were in pain John Paul Jones just
totally I was actually laughing out loud
at JPJ I loved JPJ I hope he doesn't
think it's insulting that I'm calling
him JP James Lepp John Paul Jones love
JPJ could watch him all day
JPJ all day and I just like that they
did this because I don't think that men
have a great awareness of some of the
trials and tribulations that only a
woman experiences like cramping and like
labor and nine months of pregnancy to
literally shoot a new human into the
world are you kidding
my thing has always been waxing I think
if guys want us to get waxed they should
go get waxed you should experience that
pain so I'd like to see that on a date
next what's a really painful date you'd
like to see happen that's a dark
question leave your answers in the
comments below
oh we're getting weird mmm next up the
cocktail party and Anna and jet at this
great conversation cheers again to Jed
I'm obsessed with Chad and now jet aside
as much of a front-runner as I think he
is I want to pause and take a moment for
something that's playing an absolutely
key role on the show this might be the
biggest frontrunner of all a star the
true lead perhaps chicken nuggets you
want no I'm good
you guys chicken nuggets are all over
this season we had cam with his chicken
nuggets and our Rose got the story we
had cam I'm getting distracted oh my god
how many more second give the rest of
the crew what's up guys cheering we can
with his chicken nuggets in a rose heart
petal thing and then this week they're
just eating chicken nuggets why are they
eating chicken dishes this cocktail
party
it doesn't seem super glam but I'm in
for it so drink every time you see a
chicken nugget or you know go make
chicken nuggets right now press pause
come back to rows and rows eight and
watch with snugs of your own
well done who makes your favorite
chicken nuggets drink and eat chicken
nuggets responsibly I'm looking forward
to getting some more one-on-one time
tonight hopefully uninterrupted cuz you
know I was feeling sympathy for cam but
it's waning throughout this episode
because cam comes in and argues that
he's had the least amount of time of
anyone in totality I think I've had the
least amount of time with her cam are
you kidding
you are on the live AFR you met Hannah
before anybody else did you got time
with her on night one you crashed a
group date stop yourself sit down ABC
always be closing your mouth okay thank
you and you know what I want to thank
Tyler for coming in and making this
comparison to a first grade soccer team
which I in no way shape or form saw
coming your watch first grade soccer
well they all follow the ball that's
what it would be like if we just all
step on each other's toes those that
love me I mean there's times where we
you know I got to play the game right
absolutely man yeah but it does make
sense I totally get it I'm like does
this guy coach on the weekends is a
coach kids teams because I was vibing
and understanding him Mike wasn't there
for this conversation but he would have
shut cam down if he were Tyler was a
little more patient and then oh my god
this show is the gift that keeps on
giving it's like it knows what I want
and then it gives it to me well then we
got Mike great so Mike is talking to
Anna and he tells her this personal
story about he and his ex fiance having
a miscarriage we had an amazing date
around babies and it only made me think
of a situation I had to pass on my eggs
so Mike's telling this story and cam
interrupts him not once I'll come get
you in a second can you walk outside
your doors I'm really important not
twice I'm something really important I
need to tell her three times
amen this was so awkward and so bad and
again my patience for cam is waiting
always be cutting down my patience with
Kate I actually had to resign from my
job and I want you to know that I chose
to be here for you and I don't want to
let any other guys get in the way of
that
and then cam is getting his time with
Hannah and I loved it the guys gave a
little bit back to him the server guy
who brought the pizza on night one he
interrupts cam Jimenez I'd literally
just sat down about that time yeah and
it seems even more awkward than the mic
situation though I will admit I couldn't
see everything that was happening it's a
little bit like Game of Thrones what
goes wrong it was very dark and it just
seemed horrifying like it was okay with
it being so dark because I didn't really
want to watch because they were arguing
over who's gonna walk Hannah out it was
bad Mike will you accept this race Mike
gets the Rose and I just want to take a
moment I'm taking a lot of moments today
to talk about some of the guys voices
because we hear Mike's a southern belle
southern belle of course I was and oh my
gosh I could just listen to my talk
great eyes great smile great voice love
Mike great things to say excited to get
out of here and Connor
Connors talk about going on his
one-on-one and he's like I'm ready to go
Hanna ready to go
there's a reason I'm on this date and
Connor I thought was really nice on this
one-on-one with Hanna Hanna
unfortunately gets sick and they have to
give up a ceiling day you guys this is
painful for me I need more wine for this
I freaking love sailing it is like my
number one activity sailing with the
glass of wine yes please so I'm really
sad and I'm pouring one out and drinking
for the loss of just watching the
sailing date but Hanna is sick gotta go
go see Hannah make her feel better
yeah go good
and Connor's ready to go home together
and so he goes and she's kissing him and
in my head I'm like oh my god
oh girl she's sick and then the show the
gift that keeps on giving they explained
she's not contagious great I'm not
contagious
he drinks for not being contagious long
Connor chills with Hannah he doesn't get
a rose and that was weird and I didn't
understand it but then even though he
doesn't get a rose
he left sticky notes all over the
foliage in her hotel room as he walked
out and that was really sweet and
thoughtful of him truly I thought what
did you guys think of Connors gesture
Hanna has been healed by the power of
Connors kind words and they continue
their dates and Connor gets a rose right
away and then Tyler G goes home with no
explanation I had to go to the hospital
and then I found out Tyler G had to
leave I think there's something going on
there guys I'm honestly gonna
investigate this a little bit I feel
like there had to be something
scandalous because why else did he just
disappeared we didn't see his goodbye
and it was barely acknowledged after you
got a one-on-one interesting let me know
if you're seeing stuff on reddit cuz I
don't go on reddit I don't it's too much
and so if you guys kind of learn me -
what's on reddit that's very helpful
thank you our next group date is a photo
shoot date why do we do this for a
camera you only click one button am i
doing this wrong just the way other
people do it like that's not very
emphatic and this was revealed to be an
integration with the secret life of pets
- Wow not so subtle okay I don't love
this but I get that they have to do it
you know you got to make your money so I
don't know they're talking about dogs
I'm barely conscious and then is back
[Music]
this was surprising to me and made me
wonder if maybe someone else was
supposed to come in because I don't
think they've ever had a guest star
twice on a season this was unusual to me
but Demi's back and I love this little
gimmick to like listening on the guys
and hear if they say anything bad about
Hannah are here if they take the bait
and flirt with another woman off to the
side on the photoshoot date but
unfortunately none of them did so that
was kind of a bummer guess they've got
integrity whatever they're taking the
photos and shockingly surprisingly
unbelievably bafflingly didn't see this
one coming ly Luke P is jealous Wow Wow
Wow
yeah it's frustrating she wants to date
someone and start to fall in love with
someone and have to share Luke P and his
purple sweat band that is way too big
for his head are jealous so he's trying
to get more time with Hannah and it's
like he's literally following her out of
the photo shoot and he's like Heather
does some things like oh and I couldn't
stop laughing just drink during that
moment he tried to grab me after our OSU
and Hannah says to the camera that he
needs to slow his a roll I needed to
slow his roll but I'm thinking Hannah
you need to say that to Luke and then
this show would begin he's done
yeah because we go to the cocktail party
if she says that to Luke your confidence
in this kind of makes me irritated I'll
get to that
just this nugget gets the final rose I
forgot this was handed out and nuggets
up one row summary there have just been
some like little red flags about how he
carries himself that bothers me a little
bit Hannah says of Luke P but there is a
fine line between I really think is
attracted to like its most unattractive
thing I've ever seen in life and I
couldn't agree more
it's like please be obsessed with me but
not too obsessed okay and I really feel
that way like I totally understood what
she was saying well can I just tell
y'all first again yeah hold on let me
talk to her and then Luke begins to
unravel what are the signs you start
slamming the other guys to Hannah not a
good look bro really gonna think these
guys just have what it takes
not helping looks like you are just
grasping and lashing out here then he
goes back and tells the other guys about
how he didn't have this great
conversation with Hannah and I was
surprised by that Luke piece seems to me
to be the type who would not reveal any
weakness which again then was a sign
that he is unraveling and then he says
quote that's like the conversation never
happened
what what what dude that's just
disrespectful the woman who you say
you're borderline in love with is
telling you something that's important
to her and you're going to act like the
conversation never happened
I'm not impressed with P
oh and then he goes for pilot base
[Music]
don't you dare Luke pilot Pete is
arguably the nicest most easygoing guy
on the show he's that zero confrontation
with anyone so far and Luke's coming at
him because they're both waiting for
time for Hannah and Peter has gotten
none
and Peter's literally saying I don't
know why you have a problem with me
right now man Luke chill out man he's
like self imploded this guy wants to
sink his own ship Hey
[Music]
stilted at the end it's because I'm too
drunken chicken nuggets and that Luke
says even that thoughts about leaving
here tonight oh my god honestly Luke
what a baby you were acting like a child
right now this is gonna be the greatest
play of my life
so Pilate Pete and Hannah are talking
and having a lovely conversation and he
is full of plain puns he is soaring he's
gonna make us move landing there's not
gonna be any turbulence on this flight
he's gonna have your drink order ready
to go we love pilot Pete
so Peter got the Rose what do you guys
think who is leading the pack at this
point like now I'm thinking Peter maybe
I don't know okay and Hannah does find
Luke at the end though and tell him that
she's still into him and like we knew
that but Luke you need to fix it you
need to fix it
I didn't say something pretty serious so
then back in the mansion cam calls for
everyone's attention always beat Colin
and says he's gotta make an announcement
who does this it's not all about you cam
you need to calm down
always be calm and you look around at
the guys and drink for every time the
guys faces are just like are you kidding
me Oh
then he metaphorically cheers is and I'm
like I need you to literally and then oh
my god I love Mike there's this
perfectly time to pause and Mike just
goes yes no there's no rules of
engagement yes I came here to let you
know if that there will not be a
cocktail party what so then they are
having a tailgate instead of a cocktail
party and I thought this would be such a
great time to drink my wine with my
chicken nuggets and a little mason jar
bottom line I thought I needed to make
my wine more Instagram friendly because
this was the most Instagram ready
tailgate I've ever seen why was that
vintage truck there why
it has no reason it's like they don't
even have their phones so he would speak
pictures on this but whatever cutest
tailgate in the history of tailgating
time sure
Cheers I didn't just spill I don't want
to mess up this lipstick I didn't do it
but it looks great
I like a tailgate bread you know a key
question did the tailgate have chicken
nuggets I'm not sure but it did have
camp a different seat and cam grabs
Hannah to tell her his story and I'm not
trying to be insensitive here
but I didn't understand it I just didn't
get it I wasn't clear on what his
illness was and so it was a little
confusing I was getting off work and all
of a sudden my right leg locked up on me
and all of a sudden I was running a
fever and I'm sure that part of that was
edited out him sat us all down and told
us that he was going to tell you a sad
story then Mike goes and tells Hannah
that cam was just trying to get a pity
rose I will say in Cam's defense that he
didn't ever say that I saw that he
wanted a pity rose who are you guys
signing with here Mike or cam I'm not
defending cam all-in but it did seem
like Mike was putting words in a stop
maybe cuts to the rose ceremony and
roses are getting handed out by Hannah
they should be chicken nuggets I wish
that they were or maybe tacos or maybe
little balls of Rosie okay great
anyway Luke gets his rose and he's like
Jonah I'm sorry not receive a rose take
a moment say goodbyes and we say goodbye
to Aaron Rodgers look-alike and to
server guile and to cam goodbye cam was
this fair at the end of the day I don't
think Hannah had that strong of a
connection with cam regardless of the
whole pity rows conversation so it was
fine to me let me know what you guys
think in the comments below there's also
a lot going on in this teaser footage we
got at the end of the episode Hannah
says useful
/ Peters my boyfriend and I've seen some
of you guys say in the comments you've
messaged me asking if the screaming
moment that I can't stop talking about
with Luke P is maybe just a group date
taken out of context here's what I'll
say he's screaming about something that
seems to be a real storyline in the show
whether he's genuine or not so that
makes me think the screaming is a real
moment not just acting on some kind of
group date exercise but we never know
what that it ain't there have been some
people questioning Hannah
so we also hear the Hannah is gonna get
questioned and Hannah's crying again and
it kind of talks about sex yes girl I
just interviewed Hannah shameless frog
[Music]
that interview is up aditi online comm i
sat down with her for about 30 minutes
talked tons of things i will be bringing
you guys more of that and that is all i
love you guys so much leave your
thoughts in the comments below
get a cameo from me if you want and i
love you and wine in a mason jar with
ice god this is trashy look everybody at
the end of the day I don't think cam was
a villain and we did admire him for all
of his rapping skills so now that he's
gone from the show we want to send him
away with in the style of always be cam
a rap come here to join me of course is
JC
in a gray blazer perfect for this
season's style all the guys are wearing
gray on the Bachelorette and I love it
can you give me a beat
cam is gone his journey is done told his
sad story buddy and ended his rhyme the
question though did you think that was
Fisher he have gotten a rose or been
sent out of there kim was crashing
Dacian I was stealing time trying to
slay our Bachelorette with his rhymes
but Hanna didn't fall for it kicked him
out of the man shun said you better
maybe sing your way out of here I
[Laughter]
thought that was great
yay
look what you made me do what you made
me do what you just made me do home look
what you mean me too
what you mean me too look what you made
me do
made me do made me do Wow I should write
theme songs for shows that no one would
watch